[Music]
three weeks after Anthony Bourdain's
tragic death Queens of the Stone Age
frontman Josh Homme shared a note on
Twitter that his late friend had written
to his daughter Camille years earlier at
the time Camille was mad at the famous
chef after seeing a promo for no
reservations where Bourdain smashed
Holmes guitar against a tree he wrote
quote I hear you were very upset with me
after seeing the promo for this show
which I films recently with your daddy
and his friends I apologize
Bourdain continued explaining that the
instrument wasn't really his guitar in
real life
daddy would have been very angry were I
to do such a thing
Bourdain also called home a quote pretty
good cook adding I cook my daughter
grilled cheese sandwiches what does your
daddy cook you the parts unknown star
sweetly signed his letter
sincerely Anthony along with the letter
the musician tweeted a message to
Bourdain and Bourdain's
11-year old daughter Arianne quote Tony
I miss you bad once Camille was so mad
at you she was defending me and so were
you
Arianne this was your father